nous sommes agit moins 5 du deuxième
tour et de plus en plus de personnalités
expriment leur votes en faveur
d’emmanuel Macron ou de Marine Le Pen
c'est le cas aussi des influenceurs ou
autres candidates télé-réalité qui
n'hésitent pas à afficher ouvertement
leur choix leur followers parce que
j'aime la France de tous les horizons de
toutes les couleurs et de tous les
milieux le 24 avril je vote Emmanuel
Macron
Nabilla Safia ou encore Maëva gainame
contre l'extrémisme votons Emmanuel
Macron
leur reprochent pourtant de s'exprimer
sur la présidentielle sans même résider
en France vous avez pu la France car
cela ne vous convenait pas et vous êtes
mieux à Dubaï ce que je comprends tout à
fait mais n'allez pas voter Macron et
nous emmerder alors les influenceurs
résidant à Dubaï doivent-ils s'exprimer
sur la présidentielle
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un sujet ça oui oui oui
parce que ce sont ce qu'on appelle les
Français de l'étranger ils ont des
paysages donc on n'aurait pas le droit
de s'exprimer moi ceux qui ont envie de
le faire qu'il le fassent qui n'ont pas
envie bah voilà il s'exprime pas mais je
peux pas pourquoi on les priverait de
parole alors il y a samedi à mon ami
j'adore ça me dire le youtubeur qui a
lui il a passé un coup de gueule
concernant les prises de position des
influenceuses qui vivent à Dubaï
d'accord et donc Mathieu vous êtes
d'accord avec ça bah évidemment je
trouve ça aberrant enfin si
effectivement tu aimes ton pays déjà
fait ceux qui décident d'aller vivre
ailleurs que dans leur pays qui décident
de ne pas payer d'impôts dans leur pays
non non
mais les gens qui critiquent Nabilla
sont des aigri et des jaloux jusqu'à
preuve du contraire elle est française
elle a choisi de déménager sur à
l'étranger pour son métier mais aussi
pour fuir l'insécurité qu'elle
ressentait en tant que célébrité c'était
ça oui
voilà et donc pardon mais qui sont ces
gens pour dire et pour déterminer les
gens qui ont le droit de s'exprimer ou
pas sur la campagne présidentielle quand
c'est des hommes politiques étrangers
qui donnent leur avis là on dit rien et
quand c'est Nabilla on critique mais
arrêtez la vérité c'est que vous êtes
des aigris et des jaloux
Maëva gainame j'adore Nabilla je les
suis j'adore regarder
l'heure c'est pas du président
on assure qu'elle a le droit d'avoir
c'est juste voilà ça va pas être là
et vous de leur mot j'ai hâte de vous
entendre franchement c'est du mépris de
classe au nom de quoi vous dites ça
franchement Nabilla elle a une vraie
vision de la société française elle
réfléchit à tout elle est impliquée elle
a des accents citoyens quoi
arrête arrête je comprends que tu vas
défendre pas non plus
de toi tu veux qu'on parle de toi ça
m'intéresse personne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi
delphineuse mais c'est une citoyenne et
un cerveau
pour pour dire que tu as envie de voter
tu es intéressé
le cousin de marine poulet
influenceuses ou les influenceurs si
elles donnent leur avis sur sur des
intentions de vote qu'elle le fasse avec
un argumentaire en fait pas juste ok je
vote un tel ou Intel mais je vote un tel
ou un tel parce que et là en fait un peu
plus par exemple moi j'attends pas ça de
mes influenceuses je regarde pour kiffer
et tout j'ai pas envie qu'elle me parle
de politique on parle de politique tout
le temps il y a pas de souci mais moi je
m'emmène ailleurs je voyage avec Nabila
il y a deux trois semaines
non mais t'avais dit qu'ils sont ces
gens qui donnent des leçons sur qui
voter ils ont pas la vie des Français
etc etc moi je me dis que si elle veut
donner son avis quel dessin mais en
attendant elle a pas la vie des français
elle a pas la vie des gens elle est
là-bas à Dubaï au soleil a fait son
business pour certains il touche 200000
euros par mois elles sont complètement
déconnectés des Français et quand tu dis
elle est partie de la France parce
qu'elles sont tes pas en sécurité en
tant que célébrité ah bah oui mais elle
dit de revoter pour le même président
pour qu'il dépense de sécurité
pour la même personne tu vois c'est
compliqué moi moi je respecte s'ils
veulent donner leur relation
non je crois ah oui ah oui ah oui ah oui
88 % c'est normal